donc en bas c'est la suite on passe à
l'hyper view de marc blondel
pour toi soit donc marc blondel
secrétaire général de force ouvrière
smaïn linda hardy laurent ruquier
thierry ardisson donc vous êtes
secrétaire général donc de force
ouvrière depuis 1989
vous êtes un personnage de la vie
syndicale politique médiatique vous avez
une de personnages truculents
vous n'êtes pas votre cigare la médaille
est sous les fumées souvent le cigare ça
fait partie de votre votre panoplie
généralement l'après midi mais pas sur
des plateaux de télévision et qui ont
régné l'autorisation je vous donne
l'autorisation
les yaks les animateurs n'ont pas droit
de fumer à la télé avant il avait le
droit mais maintenant si on me met un
cendrier je les apporte chez nous
dérange aussi modérée chez nous y'a
aucun problème je suis ensuite la guerre
je skie pour marquer ce que vous avez
vos bretelles soudoyer minutes on peut
les voir si je vais être sûr c'est le
vrai et et l'hiver valait une écharpe
rouge un petit peu ça dépend des
périodes d'arrêt en périodes un peu
agité oui merci à l'écharpé rouge les
grèves de 95 xavier l'écharpé rouge et
vous buvez alors salut je termine la
panoplie fin je bois mais dit quoi tout
de suite de la mousse une petite mousse
bien fraîche de rien et modérément sur
les modèles
voilà et on dit aussi vous avez une
grande gueule mais enfin nous sommes on
en jugera
on en jugera bon alors les reproches
qu'on vous fait on va on va essayer de
tirer au clair tout ça on dit que vous
êtes match où on vous soupçonne d'être
manipulés par les trotskistes on dit que
vous êtes conservateur enfin bon on va y
venir vous aurez le loisir de répondre à
tout ce qu'on raconte sur vous en tout
cas merci d'être là c'est après beaucoup
d'hommes politiques durant la saison
mais ravis d'accueillir un leader
syndical lors va raconter un peu votre
vie vous êtes un enfant du nord vous
êtes né à courbevoie en 1938 mais par
accident absolument mon père a été été
militaire il a été affecté à la caserne
charasse à courbevoie
je suis resté 15 jours à courbevoie oui
je peux emmener ce prêt je suis rentré
dans mon père a quitté l'armée à cause
de l'algérie ça donc j'ai eu une enfance
dans le nord hénin liétard à 50 m des
du terril et vous dit quand je serai
mort j'aimerais qu'on répandent mes
cendres sur le même terrible donc c'est
vraiment un attachement très profond
alors vous montez la paris vous
descendez à paris plutôt parce que vous
étiez un allié tard pour faire du droit
et en fait pour payer vos études les
faits tout un tas de métiers auxiliaires
des ptt camelot sur les marchés et
décharger les cases joutes salanon
garçons de café c'est sympa car oui
c'est ce que de souvenirs que je garde
le meilleur déjà parce que c'est un peu
un endroit où on voit beaucoup de gens
différents
et puis je dirais même la profession
elle-même à l'époque il y avait beaucoup
de garçons de café qui étaient en fait
des gens qui étaient un petit peu en
rupture de société et la mousse était
gratuite en même pas je demandais j'ai
demandé à serge khalfon de basculer la
lumière merci serge donc maintenant on
va passer à deux dates importantes on a
commencé vie perdues dont vous pouvez
poser des questions à marc blondel dit
la prochaine draft
il ya deux dates importantes qui ont
marqué votre vie en 1958 donc vous
rentrez à est faux et en 1961 vous
rentrez au grand orient de france vous
devenez francs-maçons sous la férule je
dirais de fred zeller ensuite chez fo
visé passage croyez d'habitude si on dit
aux gens vous êtes trop mince moi je
pense que tout le monde le sait le sens
inverse
la discrétion en matière de maçonnerie
c'est simple ce sont les motards vous
parlez on n'a pas le droit on n'a pas le
droit en principe de dénoncer en quelque
sorte à maçon mais hamas on a toujours
le droit de dire qu'il l'est à partir de
ce moment là comme je les dis bien
aucune raison quand on me le répète
c'est une vérité d'évidence voilà alors
vous gravissez otan-russie un maçon
s'offrant à lui c'est un passant qui
s'est gouré sur son audience éclair donc
vous gravissez tous les échelons donc à
l'intérieur de fo et en 89 vous
remplacer andré bergeron et vous devenez
secrétaire général de fo alors on a
accusé la fo d'avoir été fomenté par la
cia à l'époque du stalinisme en lui je
suppose que si ça avait été le cas il y
aurait eu suffisamment d'argent pour que
nous ayons un patrimoine et que ce style
il a fallu en 1904 en 1989 que j'arrive
pour que nous soyons dans nos murs fred
zeller donc est le grand maître du grand
orient quand vous êtes rentrée a été
secrétaire de trotski frais et vous vous
dites si j'étais pas rentrer au grand
orient je serais devenu un voyou
j'ai fait des choses illégales alors
quelles sont ces choses illégales dans
le grand orient vous a sauvé écoutez
courant aisément que les choses
illégales même si à pointe-claire
prescription dans les magasins nous
étions guerre d'algérie monsieur-là mais
dites nous si vous êtes ces jeunes à ce
qu'il sait pas il ya plein de jeunes qui
regardent et justement de la guerre
d'algérie il se trouve que pendant la
guerre d'algérie je me suis bouvier je
me suis mouillé pour l'indépendance
l'algérie avait porté des valises
ce qui fait que j'ai fait des choses qui
étaient des choses que l'on fait quand
on est très jeune et qu'on aime
l'aventuré surtout quand on y croit et
des amis m'ont orienté et j'ai connu
fred zeller à ce moment-là et fred
zeller et entend entre autres parce que
on parle toujours de secrétaire
secrétaire de trop ce qui met enfin il a
eu aussi les activités politiques
importantes c'était une relation de blum
etc
et c'est un peintre
il a su un petit peu me stabiliser au
moment où j'aurais pu être déséquilibré
et progressivement c'est lui qui m'a
orienté vers le grand orient alors
justement vous dites que dans vous
avouer que cette formation vous me
torturer pas je le dis tout chez nous je
réponds je pars la russie était certaine
raison et vous êtes très gentil clérical
alors quand ils font travailler avec
requin on vous disiez c'est quand même
énorme ça une chance et un catholique et
je veux pas le voir
non je ne suis pas sûr a commencé par
dire que c'est pas vrai ça me semble
être d'une maladresse je ne crois pas
capable d'une causerie de ce genre donc
le jour où je vous donnerai la proc je
suis l'amendé je suis capable non mais
je crois quand même comprendre je lui
capable de dire en privé effectivement
j'aime autant passer par celui ci parce
que ouais il est de bon ceci étant moi
mes interlocuteurs sont ce qu'ils sont
de leurs engagements sont des
engagements individuels ou une petite
que les miens c'est vrai que je les
respecte ainsi c'est vrai qu'un syndicat
ici est plutôt protestants généralisera
sa prothèse même était tellement facile
qu'est-ce que vous pour moi je
revendique ce que je dis qu'est-ce que
qu'est ce que vous pensez de la décision
enfin là la proposition qui a été faite
en angleterre que les francs maçons qui
était dans la fonction publique
ce soit officialisé c'est ça ressemble
étrangement à celle effet pétain
pourtant c'est l'angleterre de tony
blair c'est pas la france du maréchal
pétain
peu importe ça ressemble étrangement à
ce effet pétain je vous rappelle qu'ils
avaient une liste je fais et que les
fonctionnaires recevaient s'engager à ne
pas être franc maçon pour pouvoir
fichiers moi je suis contre toutes les
discriminations
alors oui les distributions religieux on
vous accuse nous ont dit vous êtes
manipulés par les trotskistes et c'est
vrai que votre élection en 89 été
favorisée par les par les trotskistes
vous êtes un proche de de pierre lambert
alors pierre lambert faut dire aux gens
c'est un cetain cette partie en face et
le parti communiste avec ce parti
communiste internationale c'est le
mouvement pour un parti des travailleurs
c'est la gauche de la gauche ça un petit
groupuscule trotskiste
c'est vrai vous êtes manipulés par eux
écoutez c'est une question très délicate
à répond donc vois pas ce que je
je manque de franchise c'est parce que
comme on sous-entend tous toujours que
les trop ce qu'ils sont clandestins vous
comprendrez bien que toutes mes
pétitions de principes vont être le
serviront à rien la même un nouveau
confrère qui l'a très bien écrit celui
là bien qu'il ait fait le bouquet à la
commande par les socialistes
oui ce livre sociaux sur blondel qui en
définitive il ya 80 pas sur blondel et
200 surtout notre ciblons lamberti smn
réellement bon mais peu importe peu
importe
écoutez non je ne suis pas trop juste
alors dites moi à votre bête noire bon
ces matches-là six mois le couple
les extraordinaires du syndicalisme
français c'est nicole notât et marc
blondel s'est vraiment alors au début
quand vous faisiez un certain nombre de
réflexions sur nicole notât je me disais
effectivement comme beaucoup de gens
vous étiez macho et tout ça en fait pas
du tout je crois que vous avez une vraie
ambition qui est de réunir au fond force
ouvrière et cgt puis ça s'est très c'est
le rêve du front unique ouvriers la
preuve c'est qu'en 95 comme investir et
la main de vienne est d'accord 1
maintenant que c'est un pépère à la
retraite viennent mais je vais vous
expliquer tout ça c'est d'ailleurs en
plus comme ça fait rire bon d'une part
il ya moins expliquez moi est ce que ce
n'est pas normal le jour où nous lançons
un mouvement public de grève
c'est en novembre 95 nous descendons des
gobelins et cetera on déambule dans
paris tours dont 5 km il est à deux
mètres de moi n'y a pas un moment où on
serre la main sur la même revendication
nous étions contre la sécurité sociale
contre le plan juppé nous défendions les
retraites et cetera ya bien un moment où
alors fort n'est pas moi je veux bien
que je fais un frère ennemi mais on peut
venir obligé en sait rien qu'on rend
plus alors j'ai donc serré la main vient
d il ya eu un pataquès ça je vous dit
nicole notât vous avez fait la bise à
nicole notât j seulement on va y venir
ça le brésil a terminé et je serre la
main vianney tout le monde etc
vous savez l'important de cette histoire
c'est que dans le la mythologie
syndicale la véritable réunification
syndicale ce serait la cgt et fo c'est
ça la chaussée semblerait je le prends
ouvriers eric ccl fo qui revient
unique mais fou le fond ouvriers alors
quand chirac s'il était mis en 95 marc
blondel a cru aux promesses de chirac
c'était l'époque où chirac et des
moulins soit guillaume sauvage et six
mois terminées c'était l'époque où
chirac était pour la fracture sociale en
rappeler le tchi parce que c'était
l'époque jusqu'au 26 octobre 95 chirac a
été révolutionnaire gauche après j'ai
appris de lui balladuriens le 26 octobre
95 donc vous vous avez cru aux promesses
de chirac de chez nous vous permettez je
me suis cassé votre démonstrative à une
démonstration une explication est à
thierry ardisson
vous avez cru m'attendais pas excusez
moi monsieur blondel vous avez cru non
je fais les choses en ordre gouzien
découvrir moi je n'ai pas attendez vous
avez cru marc blondel vous avez cru que
chirac j'avais cru en chiraquie vous
avez promis de pas toucher la sécu quand
le plan juppé est arrivé d'y avaient cru
en jambes quand le plonge le tchi kan le
plan juppé est arrivé vous avez vécu ça
comme une trahison et nota s'est allié
avec juppé et vous vous êtes retrouvé
excusez moi le cocu de la ferme et en
plus vous cherchez ti et la coquille
chercher tous les conflits mais j'ai
fini ma d'aimantation comme bon alors je
vais votre démonstration je vais
l'étayer ah voilà que diriez vous d'un
candidat qui vous présente un texte en
vous demandant de le travailler
je dirais que et un texte sur la
sécurité sociale girex et bien oui et
que ce texte en plus c'est vous qu'il
freinait un peu oui
et puis ce texte a été présenté et c'est
sur la base de ce texte que la campagne
est parti pour monsieur chirac et le 25
octobre effectivement il change
complètement général a dit rien les
geôles enfants et point la position il
se rallie à la pensée unique est allé
coller m'envahit venir à la fameuse
pensée unique
alors effectivement je j'ai fait savoir
que j'étais mécontent et nicole notât
pendant ce temps là qu'est ce qu'elle
fait elle s'allie avec chirac elle fait
surtout c'était juppé devient super est
sage et le soliloque c'est pareil elle
fait ce qu'elle veut ce qu'il faut dire
quand même c'est que vous gériez puisque
c'est des syndicats qui gèrent les les
les caisses par ce système
c'était le le cnam
c'est un leader oui la cnav qui assure
la présidence
c'était vous qu'il gériez c'est quand
même 600 milliards de francs à gérer
vous êtes donc je suis quand vous gérer
mais je peux vous raconter ma ronde et
on viendra après sur votre suggéré sur
votre train de vie qui n'a rien de
nextradiotv vous parce qu'on a des
photos quand même mais je suis 100 quand
on a six ans à 600 milliards à sac les
promus s'attaque en déça frère et des
copains placés autour d'eux que je vous
racontais la présidence de jacques damez
bénévoles t'es pas une société anonyme
on peut placer la présidence de la cnam
et bénévoles les 600 milliards
ces 600 milliards qui passe il n'y a pas
un moment où il ya 600 milliards c'est
de l'illusion c'est oublier l'argent
allongé ressort immédiat rien perdu du
tous et c'est nous qui avons refusé de
présenter un candidat parce que
nonobstant les grèves si nous
présentions un candidat il avait des
chances d'être élu pour pour faire
passer la réforme
on me disait les ministres me disait
blondel il faut présenter un gars de fo
pour que la réforme passe
et comme je pense est loyal je disais je
regrette comme je suis contre la réforme
je n'irai pas faire le contraire de ce
que nous avons choisi moi je suis loyal
nous n'avons pas accepté et j'ai eu
raison
la preuve cette année encore il va y
avoir un déficit est difficile à
justifier
qui va justifier la reprise en main et
les conseils 30 petits milliards
seulement sept jours oui mais comme il y
en a eu 15 l'année dernière et comme les
5 milliards se transforment ont
vraisemblablement entre 15 et 19
on va avoir un déficit de 30 milliards
cumulés en deux ans si vous voulez on se
revoit la fin d'année prochaine les
mepha martin non plus bas marine elle le
trompe il au téléphone
merci martine martin martine aubry
martine aubry soit une gentille premier
blanc mais j'aimerais bien vous
continuez votre numéro un c'était
marrant ça c'est l'esprit parvenir on va
en revenir à nicole notât savez dans
l'événement du jeudi vous avez déclaré
en 97
cc c'est là qu'on vous accuse est
accusée de d'être macho moi mon boulot
c'est pas de faire l'amour avec les
premiers ministres que ce soit juppé ou
je sais pas quand juppé partie madame ne
t'a est une femme seule depuis que juppé
l'a quitté vient alors le pire
no tav en vacances dans le sud de
l'espagne parce que les taureaux ont les
crocs
blondel est un amateur de corridas les
seuls metz auquel assistent marc blondel
ce sont les corridas non mais
j'assumerai volontiers mais vous rendez
compte que ça signifie je sais ce qu'on
attend même à l'extrême ça laisserait
supposer que vous avez un jeu d'aventuré
au taureau alors je suis vraiment je
sais quand même ce que je dis croyez moi
monsieur invite testicules il a pas
l'exacte c'est exact
oui c'est que à la sollicitation d'une
de vos fonceur jolies filles d'ailleurs
donné de nom de l'événement du jeudi
benhamou téléphone à 11 heures pour me
dire je voudrais que vous fassiez une
interview rapide sur les routiers
étaient bien là l'un des routiers je
t'ai pas chaud parce que j'en avais fait
une pour le nouvel observateur
la même semaine c'est la correcte j'ai
reçu cette jeune dame nous sommes allés
en vitesse manger des pizzas
je partais excusez moi à marseille en
avion elle commence par revenir vous
nous croyez pas de cocu le cocu
magnifique ce que vous venez de dire
d'arrivée c'est un peu la pression que
ça va je suis un sudoku de quoi quant au
delà vous adonner à la presse c'est pour
ça que la faille à un petit petit peu
d'élégance
quand on est connu c'est pas bien et
quand on pense le palais très con a
accusé d'être cocu sa plainte
gemalto le gagner je ne sais pas je ne
sais pas si c'est le rôle d'un
journaliste de faire remarquer mais peu
importe on ne s'attire pas les baumes
bonnes grâces de la personne qu'on
interview si on commence comme ça voilà
alors ma réponse était de 10 g moi je
tiens pas agir est obligatoire les
bonnes phases de jeu mais c'est le film
différencie des autres
oui oui bien sûr mais non je ne veux pas
vous banalisez j'avais bien raison
je réponds à cette jeune fille dans le
ton de ce qu'elle est là elle m'a dit
alors je lui réponds non je ne me sens
pas aux cocus parce que moi mon rôle ce
n'est pas de faire l'amour avec les
premiers ministres
voilà à bien et si vous me permettez
parce que moi je n'ai pas peur d'aller
jusqu'aux précieux
le taureau et les couilles et j'ai même
dit me croyant tout à fait sympathique
mes copains vont dire il n'aurait pas dû
lire celui croyant tout à fait j'étais
leur la pizzeria lagarde s'était fait
pas un petit coup un petit malin j'ai
dit
d'abord parce que je ne suis pas
homosexuel vous avez dit que c'est ce
qui m'a valu je suis dit je ne suis pas
payé qui m'a valu un retour de bâton
avec jésus est volontairement et avec
beaucoup de sympathie d'ailleurs j'ai
reçu les gens de sos homophobie en
disant écoutez les gars là faut pas vous
bourrez moi je suis respectueux de la
cour du comportement des uns et des
autres c'est très clair alors moi je
n'ai pas de discrimination
est ce que vous êtes et ce que vous
croyez à l'est des classes et est ce que
est ce qu'on croit à la lutte des
classes est ce qu elle existe ou
n'existe pas de ce seul problème lorsque
vous avez dit si on est si on ne veut
pas que je sois jaloux d'un riche il me
faut les mêmes commodités sinon je brûle
son château donc là c'est même pas la
lutte des classes est pas c'est en 1917
c'est 1789 mais je vous fais moi je les
luttes des classes non le problème c'est
ludique la suprenante c'est savoir si
les classes existe bien sûr les classes
existe donc un point c'est tout après le
reste c'est la démocratie
morton grands soirs comme arlette
laguiller
j'ai peut-être été en position d'être
plus près du grand soir qu'arlette
laguiller où elle ne sera peut-être plus
près le deux mâts j'en sais rien ice en
france or c'est le 13 juin prochain on
avait ce court mais bon ça va tu sais ça
la révolution vous alors justement on
parlait de château vous alors vous êtes
irréprochable à ce niveau là parce que
vous habitez dans un cinquième set
ascenseur plaine saint denis dans un
appartement qui donne ou que je suis
content à l'isen sur l'autoroute c'est
vrai qu'il a besoin de routine ou payer
14 mille francs par mois vous aurez à
une époque où tous les hommes politiques
ou les les gens qui sont dans le système
s'enrichissent cgil est en semi francs
par an à sagem sensations mais là il a
une confusion entre mon salaire et
oui si votre salaire 14 mai francs pour
15 15 et votre loyer alors maintenant
vous l'avez déjà 4000 donc on peut pas
dire en tous les cas apparemment oui
mais il ya une poésie et et nouveauté à
ils ont fait l'ascenseur non il n'aurait
pas voulu faire la zone c'est nicole
notât qu'il porte pour monter les étages
tous âges comme ça je dis franchement je
trouve ça très respectable j'habite
j'habitais parce que c'est ça la
nouveauté depuis dimanche et changer
j'habite
j'ai dit non d'aller des ménages alors
que ce but est venu du président wilson
c'est à dire à quelques 400 m du cela
vous avez 40 de stade de france
et j'habite maintenant dans sur paris
dans le 12ème arrondissement et un petit
appartement où là il ya de deux étages
via l'ascenseur
est-ce que vous avez excuser la télé
parce que ça vienne le jeu j'ai la télé
depuis je suis dans un sens oui j'avais
terminé langues et ya pas de risque mais
non je n'en voulais pas de télé ou les
pâtes et mais peut-être que nous voulons
pas la télé je voulais me protéger aussi
puisqu'on vous en donne envie on peut on
peut être fasciné pour la chose quand
vous aviez toujours chez cappelle par la
force des choses vous avez remarqué j'ai
un petit estomac bien rond je suis bien
j'ai aussi une différence entre vous et
roland dumas à terre que vous aviez
vraiment qu'apple c'est pas quelque
chose de très dispendieux s'est pas
donné non plus c'est pas donné non plus
alors vous êtes fidèles et tricot quand
même
pardon c'est quoi ça
ils vendent en gros alors que l'on
parlait tout à l'heure de votre mariage
d épouser votre je sais pas comment on
peut dire josiane gaubert que qu'on
surnomme cacahuètes je trouve assez
rigolo d'ailleurs monsieur plus excités
votre secrétaire en même temps non oui
c'est une militante ceux que je connais
depuis très longtemps et qui a été ma
secrétaire mais qui encore mal sur la
terre et que j'ai épousé il ya deux ans
d'épouser sa secrétaire clinton à pina
pas faire est ce que est ce que c'est
vrai que des fois pour impressionner les
gens qui viennent dans votre bureau pour
leur montrer quand même que qui c'est
raoul est ce que c'est vrai qu'il faut
que je tiens vous vous jetez vos
dossiers comme ça par terre et et
josiane été obligés sinon c'est pas je
profite de vous une marche et des
valises
alors est-ce que ça va avec l'image du
bonhomme qui refuse la discrimination
non bon alors non au contraire je suis
relativement attentionné avec quelqu'un
mais nous réussissons d2 on va voir les
très très sympa nous nous réunissons
quelque chose qui est très très
difficile avait quitté apéricubes c'est
difficile de travailler avec la personne
avec laquelle on vit parce que c'est
parfois très délicat de faire la
différence entre l'activité
professionnelle ou enfin le militantisme
et puis la vie de tous les jours
et puis on pourrait avoir une tendance à
projeter les petits ennuis de la vie de
tous les jours dans le travail ou
réciproquement
eh bien on arrive sens et pas une règle
c'est une règle non écrite
on arrive l'un et l'autre à oublier ce
genre de choses ceci étant je lave ou
soit souvent ah oui c'est peut-être ça
qui est ça c'est vrai que c'est mignon
cacahuètes gentil bike au départ quand
vous avez engagé cacahuètes elle était
tuque
allez les gars on m'a maudit qu'il
résistait dernier le gouvernement met
c'est pour ça qu'on aime mais ses autres
jack est là si vous m'entendez cela vous
règlerez vos problèmes avec ses il sait
se faire entendre
faut bien comprendre c'est pas facile
d'être la femme d'un la femme et la
secrétaire d'un militant qui passe son
temps à méditer
oui bon ça veut dire que y compris le
déménagement là je ne m'en suis pas
occupée c'est elle qui a tout pris en
charge etc
je moi je je vais conscience qu'elles se
sacrifie